we just met chris a few minutes ago
what's good this is chris hey guys
what's good he did not watch this movie
but he came up to us what do you think
you'll think
you know i think it's going to be a
great movie you know
chris hemsworth any christian bale is in
it i'm like chris pratt
so many chris's my name is chris too you
know you recognize us you get to be on
camera simple as that's the reward
thanks buddy
um that was nice now we got to stick
with this footage
[Music]
what is going on there reject nation we
are at the thor loving thunder premiere
we just got out of here now i'm going to
give a couple of disclaimers there are a
vast number of distractions we are
surrounded by we got people we got drums
we got fire trucks we got the crew
tearing the entire premiere down we also
have the pressure of we might get kicked
out here any second now what happened
when we were doing lightning and having
an articulate opinion on top of them yes
it's kind of a lot going through our
brain but the main thing we want to do
is give our honest thoughts and our
instant reaction our opinions about thor
love and thunder so if you guys can
leave a like uh that would be insanely
appreciated now let's just get into thor
love and thunder now if you guys have
seen the trailer there's essentially two
plots for this film mainly two plots for
this movie one is dealing with the fact
that jane foster is back after thor and
her have been broken up there's a lot of
details that are not revealed in the
trailer that i think are are so rich and
rewarding in this film as taika yta
revealed it is borrowed from the mighty
thor storyline and she has cancer the
thing that helps her to not have this is
just one part of the story i'm not gonna
give it all away because you ever hear
the comics one part of it is that you
know she doesn't look or feel like a
cancer patient when suddenly she is
imbued with the powers of thor she
wields me on there in here and the
second story is dealing with uh thor
looking for his place in this world
looking for his purpose nothing to help
him find a better purpose in life than
dealing with a thing called gore the god
butcher playing by christian bale look
i'll just get this out of the way
christian bale is we all know is he he's
known to be an all-right actor he's got
a promising career ahead of him taika
waititi knew he got christian bale on
his hands and he really utilized him
because this is definitely i'm not sure
where i'd rank him just yet christian
male is definitely one of the best
marvel villains i think to have ever
graced the screen he steals every moment
he is on screen there's one criticism i
have with gore the god butcher that i'll
get into and it's really more of an
expectation not really an execution
problem but i still feel like you know i
still think it would have made the movie
just that much better if we had that
however gore the god butcher delivers i
i think 100 there's a lot of weight to
the character a lot of pathos if you
know anything about the character you
need that you can't just have them
coming in here playing evil there's a
lot of pain to the performance and i
think christian bale full-heartedly
delivers and the makeup on him is just
excellent with this film here's the
first thing that most people are going
to be doing i noticed everyone at the
screening was doing because it's taika
waititi who helped reinvent thor for the
mcu what do you think they're going to
be saying is it as good as ragnarok is
it is as good as the only bar
authority this is literally what
everyone was doing i don't know if i
like it more it might be better i'm not
sure yet i didn't see this like a time
and my thought like 30 minutes into this
film was this is so much different than
ragnarok which is great it still feels
like taika waititi made the film it's
still really funny and it still keeps a
lot of the sensibilities that that movie
has with the humor but also the very
colorful and sci-fi inspired cosmic
landscapes and different peoples that
you see represented on screen while it's
a little bit more cosmic it also is
definitely leaning way more into the
gods side of it all you know how
eternals dealt with the gods as well
this deals with the gods but in a more
humorous colorful exciting way and in a
way that seems to embrace and confront
the idea that so many of these phase
four movies have had which is we've
never intervened for various reasons and
hey look at the fallout from that i
really liked what taika decided to go
with uh on the flow of this because the
mood and pacing and the overall tone to
me feels personally i don't know how
many people agree with me on this i i
think you do it feels very different
than ragnarok yeah and i like that it
feels different than ragnarok i mean i'm
glad it's still funny overall it's just
not the same thing yeah it feels like it
took what he was able to establish with
ragnarok and then really run forward
with that and take a lot of those color
palettes and a lot of those
sensibilities but then expand them into
something that does pack a bigger
emotional punch and something that does
build into something a bit more
interesting like if i have a criticism
of ragnarok it's just like that by the
end you know you got a kind of big
battle you know you got to vanquish
helen and in this they go a more
interesting route there are certainly
big battles there are certainly
culminative battles towards the animal
app they do something different that's
very thematic with all of that really
builds well upon the previous film see i
think that's the thing is it's so much
more introspective and it has so much
more heart like it's called love and
thunder and there is so much about love
in this film and explored in a bunch of
different kinds of shades throughout
that i just sincerely appreciate it yeah
you know like one thing i lost one thing
i wasn't expecting was just how much
thematically and visually there is this
sort of like theme about dealing with
cancer that is represented physically
and internally obviously with jane
foster who's diagnosed with cancer in
this film however also with gore the god
butcher who sort of acts like a cancer
and looks like a cancer yes he's going
throughout the film and then you see
these parallels of these people who are
gifted with these these powers yet are
also so cursed about what's happening to
them physically and what's killing them
how they're using those abilities what
they are sacrificing ultimately and how
strangely enough even with gore the god
butcher that it's all backed with the
theme of love even despite how freaking
evil core the copper is there's a really
great interplay i think between yeah
those physical stakes of a disease or or
something that you know is affecting
your ability to live and then the
psychological
rebuttal to that of how do i continue on
do i trudge the weary road of treatment
that doesn't look good or do i get out
there and live and to that extent then
if you're in a helpless position who do
you go to who do you turn to and how do
you cope with that and i think the movie
does a really nice job of yeah taking
the literal cancer storyline and
representing that in a physical sense
but then also zooming way out because in
so many of these helpless medical
situations there's life situations
people turn to their gods and i think
this movie stumbles upon a really really
effective overarching theme which is we
all deal with that problem of we pray
and we hope and we yearn for that answer
and that relief the gods don't come and
how do you deal with that and how do you
still live a life of love and how do you
still not succumb to the parasite
exactly exactly a thousand percent and i
think that you know chris hemsworth
what's great is like in thor ragnarok he
got to reinvent himself with being like
a funnier thor and here he gets to
maintain that humor but man i think what
tycho really infused in here was
something cheesy but i love the cheese
of the because it doesn't feel or play
cheesy in the moment idea of like take
on the pain it's okay to have pain in
our lives but conquer it with love it's
a really kind of corny thing to say but
i think that's like what every character
here is doing chris hemsworth gets to
bring a lot more of that pain there's
one moment he got me really pretty
pretty teary yeah and i'm not gonna lie
i cried several times i was not
expecting that i wasn't expecting
neither there was one moment i
definitely cried at myself i think john
kind of cried throughout but i just
cried yeah after a while i was just like
my face is just gonna stay wet his
chemistry with natalie portman here so
much more natural
brand new because it's great that you
get this version of thor now and you get
this version of natalie portman under
the direction of taika waititi their
chemistry just works so well like i
remember not missing at all natalie
portman and thor ragnarok i did i never
once felt like
we need jane but damn uh i i'm like thor
and jane you know yeah i have such a
different association now and i'm
talking about jane foster not just
mighty thor where she she is great in
that i thought she did an excellent
excellent job here like i've never cared
about jane foster more than ever and
like valkyrie's great the guardians of
the galaxy barely in this film when they
are it's effective all right let's get
that out of the way don't get your hopes
all up that it's going to be like a
rollicking adventure with them non-stop
there's a core ensemble and it's mostly
the actual asgardians and people close
to thor in fact the character who i
thought surprisingly had way more to do
than i expected was russell crowe and
zeus i know he's a show
no he's like a real character character
i was worried early on about how the
interplay was going to be between the
economics of storytelling that these
movies have to have and the true sense
so it was at this point in the video
where there was a complete
misunderstanding with a different
security guard and so we just had to
wrap up the review but i want to quickly
say that the goats were the goats the
action is incredible and it's
specifically that one scene with the
shadows
yeah in the shadow around the white
scene that you guys saw that is some of
the most beautiful visuals i've ever
seen this movie is full of really
expressive visuals that really heighten
all of the themes that are bolstered by
the work done by the ensemble like every
time i was worried it was going to
succumb to the economics of storytelling
that sometimes dogs these movies it
would make an interesting choice or it
would build upon those choices and when
it did have to go economical i thought
they found really great motifs about
legends and gods to justify those things
i think like my minor criticisms i think
there's some weird pacing from time to
time i think sometimes the pacing's a
little bit off but it always came back
around and and clicked for me in the end
i thought there'd be more of gore the
god butchering whether he's always a
presence but yeah you would expect to
spend more actual time with him because
yeah you get a lot of like them saying
that's what he's doing yeah but you
don't really get to experience that the
bits that you get there they are dark
and violent in a different movie you
would spend a lot more time just cutting
the gore butchering gods in some ways
are smart not to do that because it
opens you up to a lot of other things
that are really worthwhile but i think
people might have an expectation that we
are going to see him literally butcher
more gods than are depicted on screen in
action sequences or something like that
so for me it might go higher i would say
right now it's like a pretty solid 8 out
of 10 for me i matched like a 9.5 for
you yeah nine nine and a half maybe like
this was this was one of the mcu films
where i was like regardless of what the
crowd thought i loved this experience i
had a fantastic time and i can't wait to
watch it again yeah it's pretty high up
for me it's pretty great and everyone's
gonna have a different opinion and
expectation for what this is supposed to
be so go in with your own open mind
valkyrie and korg also great guys thank
you for being here we gotta get the hell
out of here let's see you guys lock us
up